as an architect on youtube in 2021 i
find it incredibly difficult
to find good architecture channels out
there
so today i wanted to go through my top
five
architecture channels on youtube right
now
[Music]
what's going on guys my name's david
thomas welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about technology and architecture
like i mentioned it is very very
difficult to find
good architecture channels on youtube
it's very limited it's either very poor
quality
it's old it's outdated or it's just not
entertaining enough
so because it took me so long to find
some good people to subscribe to
i wanted to genuinely just make this
video out of the goodness of my own
heart
to actually give them all a shout out
and to help
everybody continue to grow on youtube so
let's start with
number one which is one of my top
favorites none of these are in any
particular order
but this guy is exceptional the channel
is called 30 by
40 or 30x 40 depending how you want to
pronounce it
and he is phenomenal he's a very
experienced architect who runs his own
practice
and gives very very good practical
advice
now the only shortfall here for me is
he's based over in america i'm australia
so it is a very different
approach to architecture i guess he does
everything fate i do everything in
meters but at the end of the day
the principles are all there i give this
man credit because he genuinely puts
so much effort and so much love into his
videos
that you can tell that they are crafted
so perfectly and so beautifully that it
has taken him
weeks and weeks and weeks to put these
together so it's by absolute no surprise
that he has reached
almost 1 million subscribers my hat goes
off to you sir now the second channel i
recommend you guys go out and subscribe
to is i'm actually going to butcher this
guy's name and i'm so sorry
is lyan austria he's a phenomenal
architect
that produces just genuinely
entertaining content
if you're looking for something to be
excited about architecture and to just
enjoy watching the videos countlessly
for hours and hours i know i have
he is genuinely the best channel out
there for just
pure architectural entertainment not to
mention that he does
genuinely give excellent advice at the
same time the best thing about
architecture is yes
no matter where you are in the world it
is slightly different but at the end of
the day the core principles are
identical
so whatever he designs or whatever he
does i can relate to
and same vice versa now the third
channel i'm going to recommend you guys
go out and subscribe to is called
mooch i'm going to leave all these
channels down there in the description
below so if you want to check them out
feel free to but mooch is a little bit
different to the last two channels i
recommended
so much is a little bit different he's
evolved so much from going and doing
very creative architectural drawings and
explaining diagrammatically through
doodles
to moving more into the tutorial space
and actually growing his brand
so somebody who's looking to learn more
about twin motion or just genuinely
learn about the architecture experience
mooch does a phenomenal job of just
explaining things and keeping people
entertained now channel number four is
about pure
enjoyment if you're somebody that likes
things very detailed very clean i mean
you're an architecture channel of course
you are monster cook
is all about creating miniature scale
models
now as an architect in 2021 i personally
don't create
any physical models anymore everything
for me is
3d based on the computer there just
isn't enough
time in the day or enough budget in the
project
for me to spend that amount of time
creating those masterpieces
but monstercook goes out to the next
level
he goes and creates every single detail
of
every single house and it's so
meticulous and so
so carefully put together that it's just
so enjoyable to watch
so if you ever have a spare 20 minutes i
think most of his videos are
to just sit down and watch him put this
masterpiece together it is genuinely an
enjoyable experience just to watch his
content and last but not least channel
number five
is called the local project and it is
more specific i guess to australians and
australian architecture
it takes a lot of the architecture
around australia as well as new zealand
actually in more recent times and
showcases it and takes it through the
journey
so they'll take the architect who
actually designed it on board
and get them to explain the project
whilst involving the clients and
explaining that emotive story you not
only get to see the beautiful
architecture that's
designed and built around australia you
also get to see the truly humbling
stories and the process behind it the
decisions behind
every single decision if you're in
architecture you know that you don't go
just and choose one tile for the sake of
it
looks pretty you go there to actually
make a statement
and with all these houses and all these
projects they're multi-million dollar
projects
they're the best of the best most the
time they're concrete which is a bit odd
but i genuinely do love concrete houses
lately so
it's a good thing hence probably why
i've selected it but yeah it's
just incredible to see the thought
process of other professionals
in the same space without the judgment
of going
uh i'm going to go over there and talk
to this professional and they're just
going to give me a whole bunch of
mumbo-jumbo that i don't understand and
they probably won't even tell me what
they actually did or why they did it or
how they did it because it's a trade
secret
so i think the local project that was a
bit of a ramble sorry
the local project does some phenomenal
stuff
and they truly do deserve some love so
make sure you go down to the description
below go to their channel subscribe
and show them some love they are truly
growing
what is going to be the next biggest
architecture channel anyway that's all
for me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed it
i hope you found some good new content
to watch especially
because there isn't too many good
architecture channels out there so i
truly wanted
to just show my appreciation for them
and all the people creating
good content because it is february you
will see 28 videos in 28 days for me
i don't know when this video is going to
be up but i'm hoping we're towards the
end i've recorded so many i've put
together so many
i'm hoping you've enjoyed it if you have
make sure you smash that subscribe
button
and because it is february i'll see you
tomorrow